your live chair thank you very much um
before we start it is still quite warm
so if any members want to divest
themselves of their jackets or ties um
please feel free um so good evening and
welcome to this Northwest planning
committee on the 13th of September
20123 my name is councelor Mark darham
and I'm chairman of this
committee members we are streaming this
meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in this
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate
time could I ask members to avoid
approaching the top table as this could
create interference with the cameras and
the live
stream please note that the YouTube live
stream sound record buing is dependent
on the correct use of
microphones therefore can I ask that
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and then turn it
off when
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible and I would also add please
avoid repetition of points previously
made
members when you arrived you may have
seen there's quite a number of people uh
watching and listening downstairs so
please when you speak try and be um
speak as clearly as possible so that
those people have the benefit of
understanding uh the
debate um item two is apologies for
absence Clark do we have any
apologies uh good evening chair we have
one apology for absence from Council
morning thank you very much chair thank
you very much
I'm assuming therefore that we're
expecting sorry councelor Morgan just to
say that somebody councelor Thompson was
just trying to get a hold of me so I
don't quite know what that outside of
that was going to be okay well she's not
here at the moment so no
um okay so item three
minutes and there she is councelor
Thompson good evening I do apologize
chman
well
that's um we'd only just reached item
three councelor uh Thompson so uh that
is fine and you know the relevant um
routines Etc regarding microphones so I
don't need to go over that again no de
and there's no declaration we're not
there actually yet so item three is
minutes it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on 16th of
August 2020 23 found on pages 7 to 12
are approved as a true and accurate
record I so move have we a
seconder councelor
Sidle thank you very much
indeed item four Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any dis disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-reg interests relating to items
of business on the agenda having regard
to paragraph 9 and appendix B of the
code of conduct for members members you
are also reminded that you are required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
you become aware should the need arise
during the
meeting I see no Declarations of
Interest so we therefore move to agenda
item five which is reference
23123 land rear of nine Church Road Wick
and Bishops and um Miss herner I believe
you are presenting
this thank you chairman and so just
before I begin and there's just a couple
of verbal updates so in the members
update circulated yesterday at paragraph
5.3.7 it states that 25% of the entire
site will be first homes that should
read 10% of the entire site and 25% of
the F wall that actually equates to five
dwellings um members will also be aware
of the MP letter that's been circulated
which has been addressed within the
members update but I thought it also
worth just elaborating on the ownership
issues that have been
raised so the landing dispute is outside
of the red line boundary and applies to
um number 11 Church Road which is down
here so because it's outside the red
line boundary we wouldn't require
certificate a to be signed as part of an
application and as set out in the
members update and the committee report
officers are satisfied that nobody has
been prejudiced by certificate ab and
signed and officers have sought
appropriate clarification on the
ownership of the site and we're
satisfied that this won't impact on the
ability to deliver the site access or
the foot
paaths it's also worth noting this
matter wasn't raised um as part of the
previous appeal by the inspector and so
we're content that the application can
be determined I also sought legal advice
on this from um the legal specialist
yesterday and he's happy with this
approach
so moving on to the
presentation counc Morgan uh yes thank
you Mr chairman uh with regards to the
um bit of land that's not subject within
the redline boundary I understand is
that the one that's going to be subject
to a possible grampin
condition yeah that's correct so it's um
possible that the site access and it
would involve the site access um and
potentially the foot path upgrades um
but it's been specified and has set out
in the report that there's a legal
agreement within the site have you have
you seen a copy of that agreement I
haven't no right there's also I
understand a restrictive covenant
relating to other aspects of the access
here have you seen copies of that
restrictive covenant I haven't no
you thank you councelor Morgan
M so this is an outline application for
up to 50 dwellings with the matters of
access for consideration the development
would propos 50% affordable housing and
would provide contributions towards Rams
um Recreation avoidance mitigation
strategies education contributions NHS
and open space within the
site so here you can see the location
plan the site is occupied by a detached
Bungalow which would be demolished to
facilitate the development the majority
of the site lies outside the settlement
boundary so that a proximate settlement
boundary runs sort of to the rear of the
existing built form
here and the rear the re the rear of the
site that's outside the settlement
boundary is predominantly grassland that
appears to be being used as a padic
area so here I've provided the
indicative master plan so this was the
previous appeal scheme that was
dismissed and this is the scheme before
us
now so I've tried to um highlight the
main differences in terms of layout it's
important to note that layout isn't a
matter for consideration but because
access is the layout will largely be
determined by the internal access
Arrangement that you can
see so we have less development up to
the northwest corner um a more open
space here within the um sorry NorthEast
Southwest corner of the
site um more linear development here um
and just a different
configuration here and as you can see um
the properties also now proposed
garages so there are two less um
dwellings proposed as part of this
application and there is now also a
proposal for 50% affordable housing
that's 25 units in contrast to the 20.8
that was previously
proposed in policy terms the differences
are the National planning policy
framework has been updated the
neighborhood plan has been adopted and
as has the green infrastructure
strategy however officers are review
that the princi
um policy matters within um these
documents aren't significantly different
to the ldp policies and so wouldn't have
a material bearing on the differences
between the previous inspector's
decision and um office's recommendation
today so as you'll be aware from the
report officers are recommending that
significant weight is given to the
provision of affordable housing which is
a different stance to what the previous
inspector
found so what I'd like to do is just set
out a number of different differences
between the previous
application um and this one which has
resulted in us reaching this
conclusion so we're all aware that
access to good quality housing is a
significant issue for residents across
the M
District the short for affordable
housing has become greater than at the
time of the previous um appeal decision
was made so our Lo local housing needs
assessment sets out that we have a
requirement to deliver 209 affordable
dwellings per year from 2021 and the
majority of that is
um requirement for affordable rented
property so I think it's
174 so we know at the moment that we're
delivering less than that per
anom the 5e housing land supplier data
sets out that the district needs to
deliver 279 dwellings per annual for the
rest of the plan period that's both
market and affordable properties so if
you take those two figures this means
that 75% of all homes to be delivered
would need to be affordable housing
in order for us to be able to meet the
deficit so under policy H1 is only sites
of 10 or more dwellings that are
required to provide affordable housing
and of those sites depending on where
you are in the district there is a
requirement of 25 um up to or up to 40%
of properties that would need to be
affordable on those
sites um it's quite apparent that this
is well short of the 75% and as I've
said only applies to sites of 10 or
more this is this demon St without an
overr provision we will not be able to
reduce the shortfall and the shortfall
will continue to
grow uh this will also have a knock on
effect for delivery requirements for the
next
plan and we also see a wider impact on
the council as a home whole as
homelessness will increase and temporary
accommodation costs will increase which
will come at a cost of the
council for further
context um we've I've been in contact
with housing and um they're provided me
with some data so in July 2017 at the
time that the previous appeal there were
753 applicants on the housing register
in contrast and as of today's dat
there's
1,488 applicants on that register
meaning that those numbers are almost
doubled the applicant is willing to
provide the five additional units as
rented properties the local housing
needs assessment sets out this is where
our greatest need
lies housing have advised in the top
three bands for housing need which are
band a extreme need there are four
families on the
list band B urgent need there are 79
families and band C for higher need
there are 33
families families are waiting free bed
houses and now be in placed in temporary
accommodation outside of the district in
Wickford bardan South End and as far as
Peterborough with the wait list being
nearly 2
years it is these reasons that the over
provision of affordable housing is being
given significant weight by officers
and just also note that the five over
provided units have also been agreed to
be um predominantly three bed units
rented units which would meet our help
meet our
need so regardless of whether the sites
would deliver five or 50 dwellings over
the requirement only way to reduce the
shortfall is through this means which is
an opportunity that doesn't present
itself on every
site since the previous appeal there has
also been an appeal um scheme for 80
units in great
totam the inspector
significant weight to the provision of
affordable housing even though it's only
a policy compliant level of provision
this is a material consideration of this
application and does go towards
demonstrating the differences between
the previous the shortfall in 2017 to
versus what it is
now think we go so you got the tree
protection plan um which shows the trees
to be removed so 78 individual trees to
be removed three trees three groups and
the partial clearance of one group 46
are Cate category B trees and one
category B group the lowest value trees
possible are being proposed to be
removed in order to protect the higher
value trees and sub substantial planting
is proposed to mitigate against the
losses and just also worth noting that
it's a similar amount of trees that
would be lost as that was at part of the
previous appeal scheme and the inspector
hadn't raised any
concerns so here we just give have the
landscape master plan while it's
indicative at this stage it just shows
you sort of the level of um Landscaping
that could be
provided so here we have the AIS
Arrangement which show the um footpath
upgrades that are
proposed um it's it's worth noting that
even if the foot paths can't be
constructed the situation wouldn't be um
any different than most of the existing
routes throughout the village where
there is no continuous footpath and this
is a stance supported by the local
Highway
Authority the foot paath proposed as
part of the previous scheme also did not
ex um connect to the existing footpath
Network and as I've said this wasn't
raised as a
concern now we have quite a few pages of
photographs so I've just tried to
annotate um the views of what the
photographs are looking at so you can
see um the junction of Church Road uh
Church Clos Church
Road and looking across towards church
green
um and yeah CH more of the church Ro
Street
Scene so just to give you context the
site is
here um so this is part of the site
access adjacent to um where the dwelling
would be demolished and some photographs
within the site looking Southwest
towards some existing
dwellings so some views taken more
centrally within the
site
and did I change the
SL um so then some more sort of photos
taken from the boundar on the site so
what you can see over here is the
existing built form um on my
plane and photos taken um again in the
site looking back towards the axis here
and and this is from the access out onto
Church
Road um I also visited MO plane just to
give you an idea of how the development
um could or wouldn't be perceived from
Mo plane so this is the existing
property under construction um in this
site you see there's tree belts that
would remain and so the actual impacts
on boat plane would be
limited so it's up to the decision
makers and in this case it's the
committee to attribute the weight they
see fit the material planning
considerations from officer point of
view the Main benefits of The Proposal
are considered to be the social benefits
from providing market and affordable
homes the sustainability of the site in
terms of its access to day-to-day
services and Facilities the provision of
open St space improvements to foot paths
and economic benefits from the
construction phase and operational
phases the disadvantage of the
development is that the majority of the
site lies outside the settlement
boundary the economic benefits are
considered minor given that there's no
guarantee that construction will be
undertaken by local people and the 6%
increase in the population the
development would bring would not bring
substantial benefits in terms of the
local economy in Social terms we're all
aware that the council can demonstrate a
5year housing land supplier the only way
we can maintain this is through allowing
additional developments however the
provision of Market housing in this case
in officer's opinion is limit is of
limited weight because there has been no
housing trajectory provided and there
isn't given the size of the site it's
unlikely to be required in this current
5-year period
the affordable housing provision on the
other hand as I've said is considered to
carry significant weight this is due to
the changes in the circumstances I've
previously highlighted since the
previous appeal and the over provision
of the five rented units the development
will also Pro provide open space for
future residents and existing residents
of the
village the development is contrary to
policy sa but as highlighted within the
report and by the previous inspector
there would be no adverse impact on the
intrinsic character and beauty of the
countryside or the character an
appearance of the area the starting
point for the decision making is the lp
and the development is contrary to
policy sa however the proposal would
deliver a number of benefits most
notably the much needed all housing
which meet would meet the aims of policy
H1 and a key aim of the national
planning policy framework on that basis
officers are of the view that subject to
the section 106 being secured the
benefits outweigh the harm and the
application should be approved thank you
chairman thank you thank you uh thank
you miss her um we have three
speakers um we have the agent we have a
representative from Wick and bishop's
Parish Council and an objector we' go to
the agent first it's Mr schull is that
correct Mr schull if you'd like to find
a seat with a
microphone
um if you press the right hand button
you will have a very strict 2 minutes
which will start when you start speaking
and we'll end when either you end or I
end you whichever um but it will be at
two
minutes thank you chair good evening
counselors the application before you
tonight proposes 50 homes with half of
them affordable housing something you've
heard just now about the significant
need for this in this area this is in
excess of the level required by the
council we're in the midst of a cost of
living crisis with renters particularly
hard hit Rising interest rates energy
costs and inflation are having a huge
impact on people's lives meanwhile
there's been this significant long-term
short for in the number of affordable
homes delivered in the district with no
sign of this improving in the short
medium or even the long term the
delivery of affordable housing has been
confirmed by an AO inspector this year
has been of significant positive weight
for planning decisions delivery of these
affordable homes will be secured Now by
way of a legal agreement so they will
not be removed at a later date this
development will provide an opportunity
for local people as well who could
include existing residents who wish to
downsize or young people wanting to move
into their first home to live and stay
locally the site is ready considered by
two inspectors neither inspector found
any technical issues with the sites or
the proposals the only reason for the
appeal to be dismissed was that most of
the site fell on the wrong side of an
arbitrary law line drawn in the now 6
years old local plan that's a plan based
on housing numbers and needs for some 10
years ago needs which have been
overtaken as you've just heard explained
by the case
officer the inspectors have both
confirmed that the site is in a
sustainable location and that the
density and design of the development
are appropriate the current application
has been subject to detailed scrutiny
and the same conclusions have been drawn
the application is therefore before you
today with a recommendation for approval
accompanied by very thorough officers
reports with no stone left unturned The
Proposal will deliver a scheme that
balances the need to make efficient use
of land and delivering new homes whilst
protecting the immunities of others
ensuring the development does not lead
to overdevelopment and harmful impacts
it's consistent with that considered
appeal previously with the important
distinction that half of the homes now
proposed will be secured as affordable
housing including first homes we'll also
provide some £750,000 in financial cont
butions for local infrastructure there
are no planning reasons to refuse this
application and therefore members are
respectfully requested to vote in favor
of granting permission thank you thank
you impeccably rehearsed obviously thank
you Mr schel um we're now come to
um we will go to Mr
Kish who I believe uh is an objector Mr
Kish you've heard the instructions and
uh again uh your two minutes will be
strictly enforced I'm afraid
that's
it thank you I represent over 200
objectors who do not understand the
officer's determination to approve this
application the applicant and officer
agree this proposal is nearly identical
to 2015 the reasons for refusal then
still apply National policy requires you
respect local plans but the applicant
confirms The Proposal breaches policy SA
and none of the exceptions apply this
alone points to refusal the officer
gives one argument to tip the balance
the recent offer to add five affordable
homes are above the minimum requirement
which she claims is significant but five
additional homes is insignificant for
the district haybridge Garden suburb
alone delivers 341 affordable homes in a
truly sustainable location which Wick
and Bishops is not over provision of
five should carry very little weight
this is an outline application a section
106 agreement for 50% affordable housing
is proposed but the officer confirmed
that this can be varied later without
your approval this happens frequently
through a viability assessment the 2017
appeal uh statement States the applicant
is unable to meet a 40% provision due to
issues of viability he only agreed to
increase to 40% after the local
development plan was adopted with a
minimum of 40%
the government data shows costs of
building supplies Rose 60% since then so
how can 50% affordable housing be viable
now if you approve at 50% but that drops
to
40% the applicant perhaps through
viability uh assessments the applicant
will have made a mockery of mold's
planning process this committee and set
a terrible precedent the officer and
high court agree that Council has decide
the wait to apply you can choose to give
these homes no significant weight and
you will not create a legal risk so I
urge you to give very little weight to
the extra houses the five houses and
refuse again thank
you likewise well rehearsed and now we
have Mr wardrop who is the chairman of
Wick and bishop's Parish
Council Mr wardrop you've done this
before you know the
routine
thank
you I refer you to the onepage summary
of the many points we've sent you which
explain why this application should be
refused and to the letter from pretty
Patel MP we are not a nimi Village we
have worked with developers on projects
inside and outside the development
boundary which were provided affordable
homes and homes that met The Village's
identified needs the officer has made
much emphasis on on the affordable
housing issue yet our MP has told us
that MDC is currently well placed in
this respect it cannot be right that the
desire to improve that position should
override so many of the ldp policies nor
can it be right that the officer should
encourage the applicants to increase
their proposed allocation without
hearing counterarguments from the
elected representatives The Proposal is
so out of kilter with the village it is
outside the development boundary at the
far end of the village it is almost
twice the density of dwellings per
hectare than where in the village it
proposes street lights when the village
is a dark skies Village and doesn't have
lights in a rural setting it doesn't
propose the types of housing identified
by our housing needs survey the Char's
and Associates highways Consultants
letter copy to you clearly sets out why
this applications unsustainable on
highways and transport grounds proposals
do not comply with the mppf and the
Essex design guide is about 1,000 MERS
to the bus stop and around as far to the
shop Essex highways is own policy is
that development should be no more than
400 m from the bus stop despite the
promise to provide new footways there
will still be0 m without footway to the
bus stop children would need to be bused
to non-local schools this is hardly a
sustainable Point especially at primary
age if all the ldp policies at contes
are properly weighted this is clearly an
inappropriate unsustainable development
to quote a counselor in a district
planning meeting last month this is the
wrong development in the wrong
place thank you thank you Mr wardrop um
so before we I hand it over to members
um something you've heard me say many
times before and it's not meant to be
leading
members is that um there is a difference
between affordable housing and housing
that is Affordable and I will say no
more um and also I I'm also concerned
and it's not regarding this particular
one I think we are um missing out in the
number of supported and independent
living units but that's a matter of the
ldp review so I'm going to now hand over
to members I'm going to go to councelor
Morgan first but councelor Morgan and I
are the co-ord members of Wick and
Bishops I'm largely going to leave it
down it's councelor Morgan's capable
hands which and I will add to it
afterwards councelor Morgan yeah well
thank you Mr chairman both obviously you
and I are both well aware from the size
of our inboxes and I think other members
have as well the significant amount of
feeling this application has generated
over the last months and accordingly as
I am required as we all are required to
be not to be predetermined on this
matter I have given the officers report
and the um very eloquent speeches made
by both by all three uh uh people
tonight every
consideration and I have to say I I
commend the officers for the detail in
their report they've obviously I can see
had gone to an awful lot of trouble but
um really um I have to say that what it
comes down to in my view is that this is
an application which would otherwise be
refused on matters of S1 and S8 and
possibly D1 but is being recommended for
uh approval on the basis of this 50%
affordable housing um I am reminded back
from my studies of Virgil of the famous
phrase Timo
at
dones which means beware of Greeks
bearing gifts which is a warning issued
to the people of Troy where the Trojan
Horse turned up outside their Gates they
ignored it they dragged it in Greeks
came out and Troy fell and I believe
this 50% affordable housing is just that
it's a trojan horse because that if we
allow that in they will
undoubtedly uh seek on viability grounds
to have that changed and have that
condition removed or altered
considerably and in fact interestingly
enough there's an application one but on
from here tonight where something
similar is being attempted so therefore
I'm saying that I believe that this
there's any any number of other
objections have been put forward very
eloquently by all the objetives the
parish council and Mr Kish and uh I am
saying that if we allow this this will
be a trojan horse which will be likely
to turn up in great totam tosy the
toishan and Mand if we let it go and
therefore Mr chairman I um would like to
reiterate uh Council wardrop's words and
give due praise to the person who made
those statements which is coun my
colleague counselor white this is the
wrong development in the wrong place and
therefore I move that this be rejected
on matters of S1 S8 and D1 do I have a
second I second thank
you thank you very much uh
councelor Mr Johnson yes yeah I don't
know if Deon was going to say the same
thing as me but what I was going to put
thank you chairman what I was going to
point out is in terms of the previous
inspector's decisions on this site um
the um proposed reasons for refusal to
include S1 and D1 were not part of
previous inspector's decision uh notices
the decision notices are quite clear in
terms of the physical development its
location and its impact in terms of the
intrinsic character and beauty of of the
countryside and there was and there was
no harm found in in that sense so that's
quite clear the the appeal decisions
specifically um Point uh the second
appeal decision to the policy Conflict
at a time when the um the local plan was
fairly fresh um and um in that respect
the only conflict was found in terms of
S8 so I don't know if my colleague Devon
wanted to add to
that that was one of the points I was
going to raise but I was also just going
to come back on your point about um the
offer for affordable housing and the
risk of precedent so
this the affordable housing is a matter
to considered outline it would be
secured as part of the permission and
through the section 106 so if the
applicant was seeking to provide only a
policy level comp policy compliant level
of affordable housing they would be
required to come back to us and then we
would assess the application as a fresh
and the principle of development would
be reconsidered because there would be a
whole different balancing exercise and a
whole new consideration of the weight to
be attributed to the affordable housing
so I I understand the concerns um but it
would it would need a whole other
consideration and I don't think it would
be um of much concern at this stage
thank you can I come back on that Mr uh
you certainly can um yeah well I
understand that but I mean I'm afraid
history is lited with situations where
that exactly what has happened they come
back and we've let as it were the horse
through the gates they've got the rightl
permission and if they then come back
and say we can't make this viable unless
we go down to I don't know whatever
percentage it is or none at all then I
don't think you've got any option other
than to agree to it and more to the
point I with regards to S1 and D1 you
say the previous inspector said there's
no particular harm to the Village I can
assure you that uh there will will be on
on this development as it and we simply
do not or I do not agree that that is is
an actual viable reason and S1 in terms
of
sustainability um I I really don't know
where the the me there is uh no the
doctor surgery has closed in wicking
Bishops the schools bursting to U
capacity and you got to go down to witam
to get anything the bus service is about
to be withdrawn this is not and I mean
if they do have the 40 or 50% %
affordable housing here those are those
are exactly the services that those 50%
of those houses are going to be wanting
to use and they aren't there so that's
why I also add in S1 and D1 thank you
chairman thank you councelor Morgan I've
got you councelor white but councelor
Thompson was
first
um yes I I'll try not to fall over my
own tongue speaking about this um I I do
have a question for the office but I
appreciate their planners and not
housing officers but I was wondering how
rental prices and sale prices for the
starter homes are set in any particular
Village do they depend on local land
values or what presumably the anything
that's for sale is depend going to be
dependent on a proportion of land
values um I'm not sure that any of the
officers will be able to answer coun
yeah thank you chairman I mean that
that's not really a question for us to
answer in terms of the planning issues
terms of how that can be delivered if
there are other external matters just
like any other matter that may be
pertinent to any form of development
which is well outside the scope of
planning that would be separate
consideration but not for decision-
making thank you chairman okay thank you
chairman thank you Mr Johnson um I still
think it's relevant though because it it
I think it's relevant to being the right
development in the right place Wick and
Bishops shall we say is not known for
its low land values or low house prices
I don't think it's an ideal place to put
affordable housing um I agree with my
colleague here that um there's going to
be an awful lot of travel required to um
to access local facilities um I'm
concerned about the viability issue it
is and we are only talking 10% five
extra houses um and again I'm not sure
how you put this in policy terms but you
know we've had a
recent dismissal of an appeal in tulson
kns which is my Village of 97 houses
which admittedly was the policy
compliant level of affordable housing
but that is very close to tip tree and
apparently close to facilities um that
was dismissed as appeal because it was
outside the development plan and outside
the village settlement so I I do have
deep reservations I I appreciate the
officer's point of view and and a very
good very detailed report but I I'm not
happy that 10% extra is enough and nor
am I happy that this is the right place
for a quantity of housing like this when
I believe it's unsustainable thank you
chairman thank you councelor Thompson I
have councelor Stevens
next thank you chair yes our our local
development plan yes it's um not new but
it is still our local development plan
and we have a 5-year housing land Supply
so we're not in a tilted balanced
position so we're not obliged to be
weighing up the pros and cons of
affordable housing versus settlement
boundary policies um the H the local
development plan is quite clear that we
have a settlement boundary and we
shouldn't be just building outside of
that and it does set a precedent which
really worries me
um I think the idea of affordable
housing in probably the most expensive
housing area of the district it doesn't
mean anything if it was social housing
then perhaps but it it really doesn't
make it
affordable at all I don't I don't get
the concept of affordable housing in
such an expensive area um and it's only
what is it's not even five houses it 4.2
houses if you can have 02 of a house um
which to me even if we were trying to
weigh weigh up Pro pros and cons it's
just not enough it it doesn't go far
enough thank you uh yes
Mr thank you just in respect of the 4.2
um that is actually an error in that
part of the report which should be five
houses um so it would be five in total
as rented um and just to comment on the
matter about the plan in Balance so
you're correct then that we no longer in
a tilted balance but we still have to
apply a plan in Balance so the starting
point for decision making is the local
plan unless material
considerations say otherwise so in this
respect our affordable housing position
and the offer of affordable housing are
material considerations so whilst the
starting point is the local plan we need
to weigh that against the local plan and
its policies and so in in our view this
we've given significant weight to the
affordable housing and that tips that
balance so it's not a tilted balance
it's a flat balance but we still do have
to apply that thank you yes Mr Johnson
thank you chair I just wanted to
underscore um what Miss Mrs Hearn said
about um how we make our decisions yes
we do have the local plan and the local
plan has Primacy uh particular when
there is a 5-year housing answer plan
but it's strictly written in terms of
planning legislation and other material
considerations um these could be
affordable housing other appeal
decisions these are these are material
matters of of of equal weight when one
puts it into the planning balance so I
just wanted to just make make make that
point clear thank you chairman thank you
Mr Johnson can you come back yes
councelor Stevens thank you okay so it's
it's five houses but the appeal
inspector said last time that there
wasn't enough benefit and I don't find
that five houses are enough benefit so
whether it's 4.2 okay it's five but I
just don't find that that's enough
benefit okay thanks councelor Stevens
thank you councelor Miss
White uh thank you uh Mr chairman and
right mine isn't quite in order because
I was reading through report and doing
it um now what I find interesting is on
3.1.2 it says in the call for SES that
it's not
suitable um and in 5.1.10 there's no
there's no for path and I presume it's
not a lit footpath and that has always
made a location unsustainable with that
runs through the mppf and it runs
through the um molden ldp so that's one
one question why is this suddenly class
being sustainable um in 5.4.1 two the
shortfall of GP Place capacity is minus
268.2 3 and okay they can give a um a a
financial contribution but how are they
going to find a doctor and a surgery to
practice for so that's another question
um on
5.5.9 I'm really surprised because I
always thought that the neighborhood
plans carried an awful lot of weight in
making planning decisions under the nppf
and localism so why has the neighborhood
plan not been given any weight it
appears
on
5.9 on
59.3 it says there's a potential lack of
gardens a garden space that's uh you're
saying I know 3 MERS short from from the
indicative plan so why is that um if it
doesn't meet the m and design guide from
the indicative layout why is it
considered sustainable when it doesn't
meet the m and design guide um then we
go on to
5.1.8
5.1 5.1 1.1 5.1
1.2 now it says lower down um in the
public comments that they're going to be
78 trees removed can you please tell us
what they are on 5.11 point11 1.2 we've
got a hedro destruction presumably
because it won't be wide enough so have
they applied for hedro Destruction and
then in line of that and buring in mind
I I work a lot with nature and and our
land at home is massively a beneficial
for carbon sequestration how are they
going to cover the carbon sequestration
for this application um there's going to
be a net loss of biodiversity and
where's the Natural England nature
Matrix that should be
compulsory and um we also uh on 5.1
2.3 the there is not a full uh habitats
regulation assessment now that the
particularly the Natural England nature
Matrix is a requirement to show a net
gain a habitat net gain I know they say
well we might buy something for
somewhere off site but for me we cannot
determine this because we don't have the
full nature breakdown so without that
for me it it doesn't Accord whe I think
it's policy into but I'm sure the
officer is going to assist me on that
because I can't get two iPads at the
same time so nature I've got a big
concern we must be meeting the uh carbon
sequestration we must be doing every
everything we can to mitigate these
errors and I know that officers don't
put a lot of weight on this um I've seen
it in another applications but as
members it's hugely important so could I
have an answer on that please from
officers um and then and and what are
the 78 trees and are they of TPO quality
um and on
514.5 oh 5.1.6 it says it's a likely
significant effect why is that not been
uh given more weight in
514.5 it says likely works and we're
talking about the foot paaths well have
they put the funding in to make up foot
pass do they have permission from
National highways um is there enough
room is there enough topl have the
assessments been done has permission
been applied for um and why has every
single other application in the district
that is not on a madeup foot path and
does not have Street lighting why are
they considered unsustainable and why is
this one considered sustainable so
that's another one um it talks about
public space for others well how are
they going to get there are we going to
have children walking up roads with no
foot paths I don't know perhaps officers
can assist um and then the final one has
been touched on by my colleague um have
we have a detailed Financial viability
assessment because we have developers
going bankrupt left and right we've got
wage costs going up we've got material
costs going up we've got houses that
aren't selling we've got the cost of
living we've got the interest rate Rises
wage Rises um because for me unless we
have a robust Financial viability
assessment we shouldn't be approving
this application because I I have
concerns about it and then lastly the
last sorry the last one I've got is on
sustainability and
transport um I think it was under public
comments um they talk about the bus stop
being 900 MERS away and I understood
that the walking distance is considered
less than a meter um so how many meters
on the road not the crow flies are all
the general amenities cuz I know mop
plane and I didn't realize there was
anything that close by but I I um I
apologize I'm wrong so but I can
summarize the questions if you need so
basically it is um robust
Financial um viability assessment um the
likely Works costs for any foot pay path
creation or anything else um how are how
are members of the public going to get
there um have we got a HRA Hab habitats
regulation assessment have we got an any
nature Matrix what are the 78 trees are
they a suitable TPO
quality um do the gardens appear to meet
the modern design guide for garbens why
does the neighborhood plan not have any
weight um GP practice and why is it
considered not s under call for sites
because there's no footpath um thank you
well Miss White I I wasn't counting the
number of questions but it was certainly
a lot I think we'll let the officer
answer as many as she can if there's any
that you aren't answered then if you
could then perhaps provide a reminder
Mrs Herer right I'll try start from the
beginning you were typing away furiously
as questions were coming but um so in
respect of the call for sites and the
site being unsustainable the call for
sites is a desk Bas assessment um top
level we we've said throughout with any
applications that come forward it
doesn't carry any weight or limited
weight in um assessment plan
applications so it's a blanket approach
if a site doesn't have a foot path
currently then it is automatically
marked red within the core for sites as
I understand it from my policy
colleagues with this the applications
come forward and they've demonstrated
that those foot paaths can be provided
so through the planning application
process there's a a lot more rigorous
assessment that's taken place
um on that site as a whole rather than
yet just an overview of Des space
assessment so that's why there is a
difference between the call for site and
um the planning
application in terms of why is the site
sustainable the previous in inspector
found it to be sustainable Wick and
Bishops is one of the larger Villages
within the district the inspector says
themselves that this is the most one of
the most sustainable sites within the
district for the provision of
housing in terms of the GP capacity
again as I say this is a larger Village
through the planning process all we can
do is secure the monies towards
improving in uh GP infrastructure it's
out of our control and um to some extent
outside the applicants control how the
NHS um use that money and deliver those
facilities or we can really reasonably
require them to do is provide the
necessary contributions to mitigate
against that
um I've got
[Music]
5.59 neighborhood plan thank you um it's
not that we're not applying any weight
to it what the report is getting at is
that so the neighborhood plan and the
ldp carry same amount of weight and
decision- making but what we're saying
is the policies within the local plan
are not inherently different to the
policies within the local plan that
would result in US reaching a different
conclusion in respect of the
application uh in terms of the garden
spaces and the back toback distances the
layout is indicative the application is
an outline application with only access
for consideration so the applicant would
be expected when they come forward for
Reserve matters to ensure that all the
garden sizes are acceptable and the 25
met back toback distances are provided
the 78 trees won't pretend to know um
precisely what the species are but they
are category B trees so the int with the
removing the category B trees which
around the periphery of the site is to
ensure that the category a trees um can
be retained and protected the
agricultural consultant has been
consulted and hasn't raised any concerns
um I would be sure that they if they
felt that there was a need to protect to
retain the trees that this would been
raised with us and um they it's a
similar number and similar trees that
were found to be acceptable to be
removed as part of their previous
decision
um in terms of the removal of the hedro
this will also be dealt with through the
application um and
there's uh Native hedro planting
proposed around the edges of the site to
make up for any
losses so that that also is irrelevant
to the net loss of biodiversity so e the
ecology consultant actually satisfied
that gains can be secured through the
conditions and one of the conditions
requires a biodiversity enhancement
strategy so that will ensure the net
biodiversity
gains
um in terms of why this site in terms of
foot path is different to other sites
within the district um I appreciate we
do usually say that without foot paths a
site isn't sustainable but this the
previous inspector found that the
footpath provision whether provided or
not provided at this site was acceptable
last time so it wouldn't be reasonable
for us to reach a different conclusion
um in relation to this application the
inspector said that and the local
Highway Authority have said that it's no
different to the existing situation
throughout the village where people are
there's not a continuous footpath
Network so it it wouldn't be different
in that
respect and I think the same answer
really applies to access to public space
and how people will get there for in
terms of viability we the applicant
isn't required to provide a viability
assessment because they're over
providing we would only expect them to
provide a viability assessment if they n
providing any affordable housing or
underprovided and we have no reason to
believe at this stage that the level
affordable housing can't be provided and
as I said previously if they come back
with an application we would assess it
as fresh and we would look at the
principle of development in terms of a
policy compliant level affordable
housing and then attribute the weight
accordingly uh and then I think the last
one was transports and bus stops um
so the national planning policy
framework highlights that access to
sustainable travel will vary between
rural and urban areas and we're talking
about guidance contained within the eics
design guide which obviously covers both
very Urban and very rural areas the
provision of the bus stops as I
understand hasn't changed in relation to
previous application and the inspector
did find that access to the site
sustainable I think Michael might have
something to add to yeah just thank you
chair just just in terms of the the
viability just just just one point the
um rules around viability in and and
development is is is is fairly strict
and fairly rigorous in its application
and and Mrs herner has set out what the
uh position is in terms of this this
particular application but just in terms
of the sort of wider point on viability
and has been mentioned before developers
cannot just sort of roll up after having
a decision notice in hand and sudden and
suddenly well well that that's not our
experience yeah right they they they
can't just they they can't they can't
just roll up and say that that they
can't afford the development yeah you
know and and then we just acques um and
then dilute the scheme the and then and
also at the same time each scheme is
considered on its merits the position
here is is finally tuned we had a a
refusal for a specific reason we felt
that that specific reason was was was
overcome if that reason was diluted then
officers would clearly not support the
scheme um they would be in a position
where they'd have to go to an appeal so
that's the position in terms of offices
and the approach that we have to take in
terms of these applications thank you
chairman well thank you I hear what you
say and I'm going to let councelor white
come back but uh certainly I think
councilor white will agree with me in
now 12 years we we have seen yeah um
viability studies come back to reduce it
and and I I personally I find it
difficult
to uh understand why a viability study
is not required if somebody's offering
50% whereas it would be if it was 40%
when the 50% is probably more more
dubious but uh councilor why have all of
your questions been answered no they
haven't um right well I want to come
with the financial viability
assessment I understood that under
planning we could request one if we had
concerns I've just been Google it or or
is that incorrect I'm looking on Ricks
um so do we have the the power to insist
on it when members have a concern over
the financial viability that's the first
one and I'm really I didn't get an
answer to how far away the services were
and I'm really concerned that we've had
officers refuse small developments of
one house or two houses all the time
because they don't have foot paaths and
yet if I understand it correctly in this
application it doesn't have foot paaths
therefore it's not sustainable but
because the rest of the village doesn't
have foot paths we're going to increase
the areas with no foot paths if I've so
if I've got that correctly so they
they're the ones I don't think I got
answers to thank you let me know where
you're coming from Mrs
her or Mr Johnson I don't mind yeah yeah
I was I was just I was just going to say
we have to we have to have regard to the
to the previous decision that's a
material consideration and and I'm not
going to stress that anymore to um not
have regard to that and without being
able to justify significantly otherwise
in for example on any appeal could be
leading Us in the in the in the in the
in the wrong position um just back on
the on the viability again I
mean officers can request a viability if
they feel that the hang on yeah let let
the
officer officers can can request a
viability if there is reason for them to
believe that there is an underprovision
in terms of a particular requirement
yeah um that that that that's relevant
to to that particular scheme so if they
came in with
30% uh we would say well that's
unacceptable well and if they said well
you know that's all we can afford you
would have to submit a viability
statement just for example um in that
case they could submit a viability
statement we could also reasonably
request that they pay for us to have a
an assessment of that viability
statement and that's normally how that
that plays out if a scheme comes in and
it's policy compliant there's no basis
for you to ask for a viability statement
much L there's an over provision so I
just wanted to make that point clear
thank you chairman okay okay thank you
um I've got uh councelor Sidle and then
I think there was some uned question
were there some any more
yes yeah I think there was two questions
um the distances to facilities but
whilst I don't know the exact distances
I think Mr Johnson's covered that in the
respect that the previous inspector
found that the distance to the
facilities were acceptable um the site
does lie out on the western edge of the
village and so would be a walk into the
village but this is an issue that's
previously been discussed and found to
be acceptable um in terms of one or two
dwellings that don't have foot paaths I
would highlight I would highlight that
the um Council has previously allowed
single dwellings on mop plane which is
just to the north of this application
site and further outside the settlement
boundary where people are required to
walk along the road that doesn't have
any foot paths um and also I would just
stress that one or two don't carry any
benefits in terms of affordable housing
education NHS and so on thank you
councelor
Sidle uh thank you chair the key issue
here is previously this has been refused
uh because it's outside the settlement
boundary and that's really the main
focus in terms of the previous refusal
and the material consideration this time
is the fact that instead of having 40%
affordable housing we've now got 50%
affordable housing which is the material
consideration that officers are now
tilting in terms of of approval what we
have to decide at this committee which
is what office officers decided on this
that that those extra five houses are
significant in terms of our whole
District in terms of the need for
affordable houses so we're talking about
five houses across the need of the whole
District now to me five extra houses in
terms of affordable houses is not
significant so therefore is not a
material consideration in terms of this
decision we cannot say that five houses
is a significant material consideration
that does not stack up I can see what
officers are trying to do and I
appreciate what officers are trying to
do we do have a need for affordable
houses however it's already been said at
this committee WIC and Bishops is the
most expensive place to live in the
whole District to to to have a
two-bedroom house in Wick and Bishop
it's going to cost you at least £300,000
that is not in any way going to create
affordable housing when we look at the
houses that a few years ago were built
on witam road and and the corner of
Snow's corner it took ages for the
afford aable housing there to be sold
because it was so expensive so we are
not creating affordable housing at this
site so therefore again it is not
significant if we were saying that we
were going to build social housing and
social rental housing that would be a
different matter but it's not even
social housing that we are building it's
affordable rent the average person
cannot afford an affordable rent in Wick
and Bishop
because of the nature of that Village so
these are the wrong houses in the wrong
place so therefore we the material
consideration that this site produ is in
is significant is not correct and
therefore we cannot use that as material
consideration so we go back to the
original thing that this is outside the
settlement boundary I found it quite
offensive that the developer says that
our settlement boundaries are arbitrary
lines
they are not arbitrary lines they are
there to protect the Integrity of our
district and our Villages and this
settlement is not or this new
development is not sustainable and
therefore we must refuse it and we
cannot take into account the material
consideration of these five extra houses
as being significant because that does
not meet planning terms thank you
councelor Sid I have councelor Morgan
let you have a second go you're the ward
member thank you I I simply want to just
remind everybody the officers keep
referring back to the previous uh appeal
um that happened what six years ago and
the circumstances in Wick and Bishops
have changed considerably since then and
therefore I really don't think that
that's really that relevant anymore
thank you thank you councelor Morgan and
then councelor
Stevens I'm fine thank you chair my
Point's just been raised but way better
than I could have said it thank you okay
thank you
um as the other Ward member I I will say
um that I'm I'm totally in agreement
with with nearly everything that's been
said by everybody and particularly
councelor Sid Wick and Bishops has
actually done more than enough in recent
past for um affordable housing with the
McMurdo place which was a um a landmark
development actually for Wick and
Bishops and um and was aimed at
uh the residents of Wick and Bishops
they had first uh first um option on
those properties and and I totally agree
that the affordable houses on this
particular development are not going to
uh suit the homeless people of the
district the people that are on our list
um they're really just not not in in
that scale at all and and as we have
heard the fund m al point of this is
that had the application come forward
with 40%
affordable it would have been
recommended for refusal and it is simply
the addition of the five extra and
nobody is decrying the fact that we need
uh affordable housing or housing that is
Affordable and we also need independent
living and supported living units that
that that five additional
houses the benefit derived from those
five houses in my opinion does not
outweigh the long-term damage that this
particular um development would bring to
Wick and Bishops not to mention the
precedent that it might set elsewhere in
the district
so as the co-ord member um My Views are
clear unless we have um I didn't go for
um
to ask if there was a proposal for the
recommendation to approve I think
because I probably knew it would
struggle for a second I may be wrong but
we do have a proposal on the table um
from councelor Morgan seconded by
councelor Hughes to uh contrary to the
officer's recommendation to refuse uh
this application unless members have
anything else they wish to add and ask
I'm going to ask for a vote for that
motion to refuse those in
favor those
against
abstentions thank you members uh so that
application is
refused reasons for refusal I will let
um councelor Morgan you uh have those
reasons for refusal I think I think I
did mention them chairman S1 coming back
to you
yes and it is contrary to the ldp it is
contrary to the neighborhood plan which
has been through public examination and
has been
adopted um councelor
Morgan does not outweigh the the damage
to the
uh good one is that the benefit the
development does not outweigh the harm
no or you know various
different just yeah Mr
Johnson yeah I'm not counting what what
members say but just just to remind and
I'm sure Council Morgan's read this um
in the in the appeal decision last the
the the inspector said quite clearly
that the The Proposal would be in
accordance with policies S1 S2 H4 D1 D2
and d and T1 but at the same time it was
quite explicit that the the development
um um uh was was was contrary to the
S8 it's contrary to the since then we've
had an adopted neighborhood plan um and
those those settlement boundaries in the
ldp are
still valid boundaries and we have a
5year land Supply okay if that's the
case then we need to have neighborhood
plan policies that what we want to
include into the reason for refusal but
well absolutely because we have an
adopted neighborhood plan the parish
went to extreme lengths to get the
neighborhood plan went to public
examination and um was voted on and has
been adopted so clearly that is a
material
consideration
Poli sorry I'm just getting up can we
have an indication of I hav got the
neighborhood plan in front of
[Music]
me because concerned about that approach
because at because I'm not even getting
anything that's sort of leading me into
what these neighborhood clamp policies
are well of course we don't we don't
have the neighborhood plan we don't have
the neighborhood plan in front of us
that we I mean it's something we could
look up online I'm
sure and at page 20 of the officers
report at paragraph 4.3 the um
neighborhood plan policies that officers
feel IR relevant to the application are
listed um and they're fairly explanatory
in terms of their titles that may assist
members paragraph 4.3 of the report page
20 yes I think it'd probably proven if
we just have a couple we wanted this
absolutely bulletproof thank you y Mr
Johnson
then
well I can see three or four already in
that um group
so um I can see um policy 3 policy 4
policy
2 um W
bf2
wf3 wbh
01 um unsure about
wb2
um uh wbe 02 biodiversity natural
habitats I think that one is
it is that
sufficient wbf
02 and
03 I think it's all of them perhaps with
the exception of WBO one
homeworking uh
and yeah wb2 I think apart from that is
relevant to all of those
policies yeah it's wh1 is is designning
character yes absolutely that that is
one so it's effectively all of them
except wb2 and wbe E1 homeworking are
members happy with that
I would just that I'd be cautious of
wb01 recreational disturbance and
avoidance mitigation because they have
um there so just to clarify members I'm
assume weren't the usual reasons for
refusal in terms of the fact that the
section 106 hasn't been secured at this
stage so that um policy would be
relevant in relation to the failure to
to secure the section 106 at this stage
but in terms of the site being outside
the settlement boundary and what I'm
hearing from Members is that they don't
feel it sustainable and there design
issues
[Music]
um so yeah and I think was consent on
travel we might struggle with design as
this is outlined yeah I
agree just character yeah and natural
assets and reinforce local distinct well
the linear pattern the along the road
partage is not for housing Estates it's
for generally
umed it's not it's not normally set back
to a Housing state so that that meet the
the
design I think we have sufficient um y
so I'm here is um wbe n02 biodiversity
and natural habitats WB n03 special
views investors 04 Open Spaces 02
sustainable means of travel 03 highway
safety 01 design and character
correct okay thank
you did pick up on that in his last uh
in the appeal there was a problem with
the character as well no that's not
correct that's not correct no that's
that's clearly not correct
okay right that that's fine but we have
now decided to refuse that we have the
grounds for refusal thank you very much
members we will now move
on um we'll have a couple of minutes
while the interested parties leave no
doubt because
I doubt they'll want to sit through
anym
okay I think we're
um I think we're ready to restart so uh
next item on the agenda agenda item 6
23024 this is slate Hall Cottage lower
Burnham Road Stone Maris um and this is
a member call in by councelor Miss White
um Mr do you're taking us through this
yes chair um item six is is on page 71
of the
agenda this attempts to show the
location Southwood and Ferris is to the
west and the road continues to the east
um the sight's on the south of uh lower
Burnham road which of course continues
ultimately to
burnam this is the site location plan as
you can see there's um a single built
form on the site there's there's a
little garage on the western end um the
built form was a semidetached pair of
Bungalows however there's been a site
visit which has established that the
built form is now one dwelling Council
records show one dwelling at the site
and that's significant because the
proposal is to pull down what's there
one dwelling and to build two
dwellings here's an aerial photograph of
the
site uh the site
itself is
um is just about there and the railway
line to the south of
course here's a more detailed aerial
photograph as as it were um the the
Bungalow is to the Eastern end and then
uh there's some Garden beyond that uh
just a flat roof garage at the Western
end the um the vehicle access I think
you can make it out it's
um roughly Midway along the frontage of
it's just there where the
ctage where the cursor is um you'll
notice that there's some hedging pretty
much all all the way along the frontage
of the
site this is the existing block
plan um this block plan shows existing
fre on the site and um shows a little
more clearly the existing vehicle
access this is the proposed block plan
this shows that there would be a 6 M
wide new vehicle access just slightly to
the east of the existing access all
trees would be kept on site and there
will be two trees either side of the
Vicor access
here's the uh the elevations of plot one
um plot two is essentially the same
handed versions of each other uh the
only thing to mention here is that
external walls would be FEA edged um
boarding uh a soft red plinth and um the
application form refers to slate roof
tiles this is plot two um handed version
of plot
one this shows the uh floor layout what
is proposed is two two bedroomed
Bungalows um the uh the living area
would
be um at one end and there'd be a glazed
area um which I show on the elevational
areas um two
bedrooms this is plot two handed
version these are the elevations of plot
one you'll see that uh top right hand
corner there there will be a glazed area
um it's the same for plot
two
the closed areas would um point away
from the neighbor as it
were uh photograph of the existing
bungalow on the
site uh photograph showing the existing
Bungalow almost on the
road uh you can just make out some
hedgeway
that's the existing vehicle
access uh the existing Bungalow
and that's that's really just about it I
mean going back to the aerial
photograph um this really is in the
middle of the
countryside normally when I get to the
um the site location plan I I give an
indication of where the settlement p
country is well I I can't do that at all
this is completely in a rural site and
um the reasons for refusal are
essentially that it is outside of
settlement boundary it's an unsub
location and it's felt um principally
because of the new vcor access and
looking through that onto the parking
area it's considered that it would have
an adverse imp impact on the character
of the
countryside accordingly Rec the
recommendation is refusal
chair thank you very much uh Mr do we
don't have any speakers on this I
believe councelor white you called this
in and you've indicated so y yeah I did
um thank you now before I even start
talking if we go back to the really
zoomed out um Google Earth I'll give you
a little bit of History because I've
lived in this District since I was a
child
and if you look to the very left um I
think that's the road coming from wooden
ferrers and it goes left to um cold
Norton and many years ago that was the
only route and I remember when it used
to be snowy the the the road used to be
slightly further south and you had to go
up this hill and as soon as you got any
snow or ice you used to get halfway up
the hill and many times you couldn't
actually get up the hill to get home and
where the main road is now which goes
straight on you couldn't get up there
because that was a pretty much I can't
remember it's an exact dead end I'm
99.9% sure it was complete dead end so
when these Cottages were built these
were tiny weeny cottages on a tiny weeny
track and now they're tiny weeny
Cottages Cottages right on the main road
that goes from wooden ferrers to
Burnham and I've never been inside those
Cottages but I can only imagine what
that's traffic's like and it cannot be
safe and it cannot be healthy because
when you drive on there you are a foot
away from the side of that Cottage and
the traffic hoofs along that road
there's often lots of accidents there
now when I was a child we actually
bought a puppy off them the people
aren't there anymore and the next Corner
used to be known as cow
Corner no because they used to milk cows
the cows used to walk across the road
and the old guy who used to milk the
cows used to live in one of those
cottages and another family used to live
in the other half now as far as I'm
aware I think the family when he passed
away they took on both sides of the
cottage and if you go into the photo
that was a bit closer up you'll see
where the garden was split into two
right if you see there you see down the
middle you've got those trees to the
left was one Cottage that was where the
Cowman used to live and on the other
side was where a family used to live um
but as far as I'm aware the family took
over the the whole Cottage um now yes
it's in a rural location I fully accept
that but there have been two families
living their history historically and it
was on a tiny little lane so what are we
now we are on a massive great big road
now before I give a recommendation what
is the difference in square footage
between the structure that's there and
the proposed two structures put together
what is the what is the difference in
size cuz that's a very long Bungalow I
don't I don't know what size it
is well I'm sorry chair I don't have a
figure for that but perhaps if I show
the block plans um that would be useful
the uh well over to the right hand side
of the plan there is the footprint of
the existing
Bungalow and
um it's not it's about one and a half
isn't it so one Bungalow is perhaps half
of between half and 3/4 of the existing
footprint it's definitely smaller it's
way smaller let me go back Mr do just so
I can
get okay and then back
again so the red goes further to the
right doesn't it the existing structure
and further to the left so I I don't
know I I don't know how many bedrooms
were in those cages though I've never
been in them but there were there was an
old the old guy who did the milking
living in the first one and then a
family living in the second one so
presumably they had at least one or two
bedrooms each do we know how many
bedrooms there are in
there I'm afraid I can't tell you that
off hand because
um uh that wasn't considered relevant I
can say that with regard to proposed
bedrooms it it Stacks up in terms of um
car parking provision but the existing
number of bedrooms no sorry I can't tell
you okay um well I mean for me I don't
think think these are very much bigger
than what the existing Cottage is there
presumably um it would help enable those
two to be built and for me that existing
Cottage is dangerous I've of thought
when I drive past in a Lori this must be
awful to live there and you know I can't
imagine people do but they they clearly
do um and I think the benefit of
providing I it must be damp and cold
that house I I don't know when it was
built it cannot be sustainably insulated
heated or anything else and I would
imagine it's a very low quality standard
of um living um so my proposal is I I
think there's no more bedrooms now than
there already is in the existing
building and I for me the benefits of
building modern um efficient buildings
is of a benefit to um the local housing
stock the other thing is there is
footpath access um from the back of
these houses or there's an access track
that goes up to the little road that I
can't think what it's called and that
leads directly onto the um Essex
National or sorry the the National
Coastal path so it does have um access
to the massive walks on the national
Coastal path so for me the benefits out
way the harm and I think we should um
contrary to the um officer's
recommendation approve the application
thank you well that sounds desperately
like a proposal Council Miss White and
so thank you so is that
seconded thank you Council
wiin any other members wish to comment
councelor
Morgan uh yes uh I mean obviously I
understand the officers um come to the
decision they have because it's as he
says in the middle of nowhere however
there is a building that is actually
there um orbe it uh not
uh not separated and it just seems to me
on Purely practical point of view that
what we're actually going to get is or
lose a rather grotty looking uh and
probably i' be wouldn't be surprised
nonh non-habitable dwelling for two very
habitable dwellings and considerably
further back from the from the roadway
as well so I would support councelor
White's councelor Miss Thompson
then sorry I assume no you're you just
first before councelor Stevenson
um no I'm actually with the officers on
this one I mean a replacement one for
one you couldn't re argue with that but
it's two for one and councelor white
although highways are not objected
councilor white has pointed out how
dangerous this road is and that an extra
dwelling can only add to the problem and
I actually can't see that they are that
much further back
so I think if we look yeah I know we
um it looks from that if we can go Mr do
to the the existing where they are lit
and from the photograph in fact they are
it is literally right on the verge isn't
it
and then the proposed are to at the rear
I'm guessing that's um compass bearings
that's to the yes it is so they're
they're as to the southern boundary as
they can pretty much be
but okay um yeah thank you chair but it
it's still it's two for one not one for
one so okay Mr Johnson here thank thank
you chairman um well I was um sort of
following on from what council Thompson
has said I mean it is a two for one
um the assessment which is or the
justification for the proposal in front
of us in in in my opinion is sort of
taking planning policy and working
backwards normally we consider the
impact of development on the on the
country side predicting the in intrinsic
uh value of the countryside in the rural
areas um the justification in terms
of the living conditions of whoever May
inhabit that particular property is not
one of the the um guiding principles for
us to be supporting um additional
dwelling in the countryside that isn't
anywhere captured within our policies
now clearly with new development we want
new development to be of appropriate
standards but that's in concert with all
the other policies that would protect
the
um rural area um this application goes
completely against that um um it would
have a okay well localize in this
respect a significant impact on on the
rural area uh we're talking about
urbanization issues we're talking about
residential paraphernalia extended
beyond what exists there at the moment
and it's sort of dwelling uh proposal
that that that we uh refuse and our
supportting on appeal for that for those
very reasons but I just wanted to sort
of make make that clear um decisions um
of this nature this is clearly officers
view members are uh more than within
their Liberty to um uh
uh not accept these these arguments but
this will set a precedent for any other
developments coming forward of any
similar Manner and you can't we can't we
can't say well you know sort of living
there and you know Vehicles trundling by
must have an impact on the person who
lives here that's not the basis for us
assessing new development in the
countryside um I mean somebody else
could roll up with that argument and
quote this example how are we going to
defend that thank you chairman okay
thank you councelor
Stevens thank you I think a lot of the
things I was going to say were just said
and I would agree with those points um
just to add it doesn't really make any
difference whether the house is next to
the road or further back to somebody's
safety well borrowing some tragedy out
directly outside the property the the
safety issue comes when you try to pull
out of your drive onto a road if there
are two properties instead of one
there's probably going to be more
Vehicles so there probably will be less
safety and I think that's the key thing
not how far away the property is from
the road thank
you okay I'm looking around uh any other
councelor Morgan y well yes I mean fully
take C's Steven's Point but there were
two dwellings there originally I mean
there always been two dwellings there um
and I was just wondering purely a bit of
speculation perhaps you join me uh Mr
Johnson on bit of speculate if you
actually put the two together and made a
little terrorist side of them would you
alter your um the officer's
decision very good question councelor
Morgan thank thank you chairman um yeah
I mean I mean that would make more sense
yeah um obviously we would consider the
footprint we considered a sort of wet
area and there would be a balancing
exercise in terms of you know what's the
departure of that from um um the
existing scenario there still are other
issues in terms of um the fact that with
two dwellings you'll have two sets of
residential paraphernalia I suppose it
comes down to a judgment of how we would
assess that but that's the sort of
exercise we would we would tend to go
through um and that would be my my view
in terms of any proposal coming forward
in ter in terms of
that um but just to remind members there
is there is there is um a third reason
for refusal in that there is not a
section
106 um proposed as part of this
application uh uh section 106 was not as
not part of an application cannot be
dealt with um sort of retrospectively in
this in this particular
sense but section one6 as part of a
reason for refusal in terms of
rams councelor wind well with with the
Rams we've been plenty of appeals and
they've all said this can be done under
condition um so we could do a condition
for Rams um if the application was
approved but from what I can understand
I'm pretty sure that the the building
that's already there is at least four
bedrooms it appears to be officer saying
well if it was two terrorists or two
attached houses or semi- detached
probably it would be all right so really
we're only moaning about the fact that
they're detached and for me I still say
that that house on the road is just not
fit for person it's not safe it just is
not not safe and and for me it's logical
to bring it back um and a four four
bedrooms is still four bedrooms in
relation to cars and people driving um
and there is access to the National
Coastal walk so for me the benefits
still outweigh the harm they're only
very small cages and I think the bedroom
numbers if it was checked they would
match Mr Johnson I know you want to come
back on that yeah thank you chairman
just want to make a correction uh on
appeals um um section 106 in terms of
rams are not dealt with by conditions um
what would happen on appeal is normally
an in an appeal situation the applicant
would offer up the section 106 as part
of that appeal the inspector would
normally address that matter and if it's
satisfactory would then consider that
that matter to have been taken care of
it's not dealt with as a condition so
that needs to be made quite clear thank
you chairman I think that point is made
so um members uh I think everybody's had
their go uh we have got a
proposal from councelor one white
seconded by councelor wiffin to uh
approve this contr to the officer's
recommendation so I'll take that
first though please indicate if you are
in agreement with that proposal raise
your
hands 1 2 3 4 those
against 1 2 3 I'm
abstaining so that is
carried oh excuse I beg your pardon
chair uh that's approval subject to
completion of a section 106 agre yes yes
thank you
yes um conditions members the usual
threeyear the um um councelor white um
um materials agreed agree offic I mean
something traditional traditional
materials on WEA
board yes that between offices and the
yeah I was dous about slate Ruth but
then it is it is called slate isn't
it fit in with what's popular in the
district thank you chair that that's
useful and of course the report refers
to um drainage conditions to respond
usual drain
Etc yes thank
you thank you very much
members uh councelor Sidle sorry yes you
are indicating uh yeah um just I've
suddenly realized what where the last uh
application is and it's back Lane where
my mother lives so uh
yeah so you you have a retrospective
interest I have an interest and I'm
going to leave the meeting that's fine
um yes you're mark fr's on
sorry okay so now we come to uh agenda
item seven
23592 this is land at the summerhouse
back Lane Wick and Bishops councilor
Sidle has declared a pecuniary interest
and his leaving not I expect
my okay well I hope not she's a nice
lady
um and I think Mrs hery you're taking us
through this aren't you thank you so
this application seeks A variation of
conditions to approve plan and
permission
20490 and that was a full application
which gained planning permission for the
erection of one dwelling so the two
conditions that are sought to be varied
are the plans and materials conditions
so conditions two and
three so here we have the location plan
showing the the site on back
Lane the block plan showing the
dwelling uh so this is the ground first
floors and second floors now as proposed
so the um I think it shows better on the
next slide actually yes we've got a
comparison um sorry no I will go back so
we've got um a new utility room at
ground floor um which produces the size
of the garage and a the addition of an
additional lots of additions of an
additional
staircase
here um at first floor the garage space
which was originally store space is now
uh an office and then there's now a
twostory a second floor proposed sorry
which provides store and a plant room
and then the slightly increases the
height of the dwelling by 0.2 M and
there's also a reconfiguration of the
the family bathroom to provide on Suites
and the fourth bedroom would be um
provided as a large as a large master
bedroom with a dressing area the
internal Arrangements aren't operational
development and therefore don't
constitute develop um development in
terms of what we're considering planning
permission for the main consider
considerations for this application is
the increase in the height of the
dwelling and the alterations of the
materials and fenestration which we
discussed so just provide a bit of
comparison between the ground floors so
it's this area here the garage that will
be lost to a utility room um and there's
some bfold doors proposed
here um and then the first floor so you
can see this area is now office space
and then the reconfiguration of the
master bedroom and the loss of the
family bathroom so all bedrooms will be
unsued this is the elevations as now
proposed and as
approved so the changes to the um
Southside elevation so you can see as
I've said with the floor plans the
windows being replaced with some bfold
doors and the um bold doors here have
been replaced with a
window the materials are proposed to be
changed from red clay plain tiles old
sex red multistock brick workk with cast
stone seals to the main range and cream
pained rendo with cast stone seals to
the rear range to clay plane tiles in
burgundy sandface I I've stock leester
red stock brick work chalk render and
reconstituted stone head and seal Styles
so just to give you a few um site photos
not too much to see at this stage of the
dwellings under construction but you can
see some neighboring development in
terms of um what materials could be
appropriate with render being shown um
dwell into the
rear and some more site photos of the
access overall the amendments to the
scheme are considered to preserve the
character and appearance of the site and
the Street Scene It is considered to not
have a harmful impact on residential
immunity and the proposal is therefore
considered in accordance with the
relevant
policies and yeah the applications
recommend for approval thank you chair
thank you m hun we have two speakers for
this um we have the applicant Joy Jarvis
and we have uh the parish council Mr
wardrop Mrs Jarvis would you like to go
first I think you were here earlier
you've you know the routine so you press
the right hand button and we will start
the timer when you start
speaking oh there only one on that
one okay I'm
sorry good evening chair good evening
members my name is Joy Jarvis of Jaris
developments um I've lived and developed
in Wick and Bishops for many years we've
built two substantial Country Homes of
which we are extremely proud one being
benter Manor wiam Hall Lane and the
other lay Manor lford Road both of these
properties were built in the proposed
new brick the red stock brick this brick
has also um is also in mapole Road the
village and actually in Back Lane it is
so similar to the one that the previous
um owner um chose we purchased the site
earlier this year as the planning
approval was nearing expiration when
planning was originally granted on this
site it was a different world to what we
live in today with different materials
being readily available therefore we
required the change of bricks and tiles
which were proposed by the previous
owner to the ones that are more read
readily available while still remaining
in the same color Planet basically we
can't get hold of the bricks that he
chose they're just not available in the
quantities that we need at the time of
approval the roof construction thickness
of Timbers and insulation would have
been in the order of 20 cm current
legislation dictates it to be closer to
35 CM hence the 20 cm increase in roof
height we've also swapped over a window
and a bfold door in the kitchen aside
from these minor
changes um others have been internal
with no further impact on the external
layout of the building with regard to
wind sizes and location we make these
internal changes on our own personal
experience with regard to what we think
perspective buyers require in
2023 such as a home office as work from
home has become the norm locating this
in the roof space above the garage I'm
sorry I'm going to stop you right there
thank you very much thank you uh we now
have uh chairman of Wick Bish Parish
Council Mr
wardrop thank you this is not a simple
variation of conditions imposed by
earlier approval of planning permission
it involves the expansion of the
building in area and volume it proposes
creation of four additional rooms one
over the garage and three and in a large
roof space development on this site was
originally approved at appeal when the
planning inspector gave outline
permission that envisaged a four-bedroom
house of modest height 7 and 1/2 to 8
1/2 m without garage the then applicant
submitted a reserve Mattis application
for a six-bedroom three-story house
after objections the application was
scaled back to remove the two bedrooms
on the second floor and the garage this
version was approved by MDC since then
there have been a series of additional
applications as amendments and now this
variation which if approved would
restore the six-bedroom 9.3 m High house
with garage that was sought contrary to
and far beyond the inspector's decision
the changes now proposed materially
alter the drawings which are the subject
of condition two of the approved
application
20490 the application form states that
the only variation is the internal
layouts on all floors side and rear
doors and windows and the changes
external materials in fact the plan now
call for a construction of new Upper
Floor levels over the housing and garage
where additional rooms are to be built
the external footprint of the garage and
incorporating utility room has been
enlarged from 8.2 M by 5.2 to 8.65 by
5.5 m power 543 of the report refers to
the reduction in the length of the
garage such that P Parking standards are
not met but is then dismissed as a as an
issue this should not be
ignored these are material and
substantial changes Not Mere variations
to conditions they substantially affect
the external dimensions and internal
volumes in our view they should be
subject to a full planning application
not a variation of
conditions thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr W drop
members Mr Morgan uh yes thank you
chairman uh I um obviously called this
matter in um and I have to say basically
I mean Council wardrobe has really said
what what I really need to say and that
is it's a matter of procedure um section
73 I think of the TCH calls for uh the
variation of conditions for minor
material amendments and I would simply
suggest to members that sticking another
story on excluding the garage is is
outside of that and that therefore this
should be done dealt with by way of a
full planning application and um there
was some discussion I think in Clause
5.2.3 that this other story wouldn't in
fact uh was I going to be for offices or
for bedrooms there Velux Windows as I
understand have now been installed there
so you know you can draw your own
conclusions from that so therefore Mr
chairman I I move that this uh
application
for be uh refused and the applicant be
asked to submit a proper planning
application for these changes do I have
a second again I'm looking for a
second got a question to
ask are well is there a second well I'll
second it in the in all right then
councelor white yeah so yes now your
turn now yeah thank you I I'm really
curious over this because first of all I
thought oh yeah I've not got a problem
with this um but the I was a bit
confused by the parish counselor who
said it was meant to be about 8 and a
half met now now it's
9.2 and it says that it's only being
increased by 20
cm but I know from my experience I put
in a variation of conditions to put
habitable rooms in a roof space and the
officers said they would not approve it
because putting additional rooms in the
upstairs was more than you were allowed
under a variation of condition and it
would need a completely new planning
application so what I want to know is
why is it acceptable in this house and
not in others good question Mrs her
thank you chairman I think um councelor
Morgan's question in relation to whether
this is a minor material Amendment and
your question councelor white um inter
relate so section 73 there's been recent
case law this year that states that
section 73 doesn't only have to be used
for minor material amendments it can be
for
um material amendments but it just has
to ensure that the development doesn't
conflict with the operative part of the
permission in the case that councelor
white is talking about the description
of development is that the property
would be a single story dwelling and
there was also a condition on that
permission requiring that no Boral
Windows be provided within that
application so had the Council of
approved that application they would
have been in conflict with the Optive PA
of permission that's why that couldn't
have been under Section 7 3 in this case
the amendment being sought can be done
under Section 73 because it doesn't
conflict with the operative part of
permission councelor Morgan I'll let you
come back and then councel yes thank you
um the original application which was uh
turned down was for a six bedroom house
I believe it was subsequently on appeal
uh Allowed by the inspector for a
four-bedroom house and yet now by simply
using variations of condition it seems
as if the applicant is going to get
their six-bedroom house I don't think
that's the proper use of the planning
procedure I think that's a statement
rather than the question but I I don't
let's go through where the bedrooms are
um sure
so what what you originally had was the
master bedroom here um and five bedrooms
I think members are refer so the master
bedroom now includes a dressing room and
then you have these three bedrooms I
think members are referring to perhaps
the dressing room being used as a
bedroom and the office also being used
as a bedroom if I understand correctly
um and I would also say on the the
second floor
um the plans are
somewhere um I'm yeah guessing this is
part of the concern as well um I'm not
entirely sure on the head Heights that
would be provided but given the small
raising the ridge height um I'd question
whether they could actually be provided
as bedrooms but I'm not fully clear on
that point at this
stage can we just clarify what the
increase in the ridge height is because
that appears to be in
Conflict we've had 20 cm mentioned yeah
um I don't have the dimension on these
plans but from the officer's report it
states that it's 20 cm
increase okay no I'm sorry I'm sorry you
can't no well I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah
thank you counselor Miss White if I
might come back I mean what's the
difference s we must have a a ridge
height the original Ridge height and the
existing Ridge height on the drawings
here and is it changing from a two story
to a three story or is it still a two
story that was my question because if it
had pliss for a two story Are We Now
talking about allowing a three
story this is
her there are three levels proposed I'm
just checking up
there so the just sorry I'm um not the
original case officer she uh she's on
turn to leave and had a healthy baby
girl we pleas to know so I'm catching up
with this one so the the description of
works for the original application were
erection of one dwelling so it goes back
to the point I was making previously it
there was nothing in the description
that would prevent a section 73
application to be submitted and granted
for this application because it wouldn't
conflict with the principle of
development you have a look at the what
the original plans were yeah original
approved plans what's what's the number
I think that would be9 2490 sorry
20490 so these these this is the
originally approved PL as I understand
it and this is the proposed plan so um
just by eye you can see that you know
these these plans are to the same scale
that there's not a substantial increase
in the ridge
height
yeah perhaps the west elevation shows
that as
well have you got the originally
approved yeah they're there side by side
right
okay so that's showing that there
there's no change really apart from the
20 cm 20
cm okay okay councilor
Morgan no I I think my understanding is
that there is a another floor has been
put in with the intention of utilizing
the roof space for
accommodation I'll just answer that yeah
I mean it it it appears to me the the
additional flaw quote um is is utilizing
the space within the
roof um now one wouldn't need planning
permission to be able to use one's roof
space um for whatever
uh means one want wishes to use the roof
space I I think you need plan commission
to turn the four-bedroom test and the
six-bedroom you don't need planning
permission to be able to access your
roof space and to use your roof space
yeah what you would need planning
permission for and that has been
mitigated by um the last condition is
that one cannot have any openings
because permitted development rights
have been removed from this dilling so
no openings um in in the roof space
specifically is the last condition
whatever that condition number is um has
been imposed so that that will just be a
void space um for storage or whatever
but it will not have any Windows my
information is that velu windows are
being installed can we can we go to the
photographs noef on at this
stage it' be very dark rooms without any
fenestration of
course
okay um are we are we clear on on that I
don't Rec did the existing drawing show
that there were Vues no I don't recall
seeing that and they proposed no maybe
they don't seem to demonstrate there
there are no there are no Vues uh but
condition which I I did have a minute
ago
condition condition eight specifically
says not withstanding the provisions of
article three of the town and contract
planning um uh uh gpdo no second floor
windows or other form of opening shall
be constructed on the roof slope of the
dwelling house or garage hereby
permitted without planning permission
having been obtained from the
LPA
okay
well uh members we we have
a proposal to refuse this contrary to
Officer's
recommendation by councelor Morgan and
councelor Miss White are you happy to
second that you yeah I still don't the
information
cons Sor just just a com Mr Johns to um
suggest a reason for refusal on a
thought that we're not clear about
legally unsustainable I don't okay well
we'll go with um counc Morgan's
suggestion and um I think that they're
asking for more than would normally be
allowed under the application terms um
by creating um potentially habitable
accommodation upstairs and we've got no
information on Ridge Heights and roof
space and I think we've got
insufficient um information to determine
what the future use may be in in light
of living standards and and whatever
else you call it hence the need for a
planning application okay councelor
Morgan is the solicitor so we have a yes
Mr Johnson thank you Ju Just to be clear
I mean if you're if we're talking about
applying living standards to a roof
space in which one can use a roof space
without needing PL permission you can do
on any house yeah as long as it's not
subject to a condition this is a new
dwelling and specific conditions are
being proposed so I'd be mindful if
members are using standards which are
not supportable under planning
legislation that would be very put us in
a very difficult position no no doubt
the applicant can make that point to you
when he makes his
application okay so there we have the
proposal to refuse country to officers
recommendations in the name of councelor
Morgan seconded by councelor Miss White
indicate those in favor
please that is
two those
against that is four so
that is
granted technically that uh as the
proposal
fails we have to go back to the
substantive um which is the officer
recommendation to
approve those in
favor sorry
members yeah would you like that propos
second
it can be yes it needs to be proposed
the substantive motion is
now right okay and so please indicate
those in
favor four those
against two so that application is
granted thank you very much members
thank you for your patience thank you
for your diligence tonight because it we
always knew this was going to be a
difficult meeting and I think we've
dealt with this very um correctly and
successfully uh item eight on the agenda
any other items of business that the
chairperson of the committee decides are
Urgent you'll be pleased to hear I have
none so I therefore close this Meet
close this meeting at 9 looks about 22
thank you very much members thank you
chair